hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
with an old friend Amy from savvy sexy
social and a new website vlog like a
boss to celebrate the launch of her new
book that just came out on how you can
have success as a vlogger on YouTube
Amy great to have you back on Evan I'm
so happy to be back thank you for having
me I love that I can join you in this
whole book club thing isn't that cool
yeah I didn't know that our books were
gonna be so closely I know it was it's
fun anyway so today we're talking about
tips and tricks for YouTube success I
want to touch on your book and
everything that you're highlighting in
there but kind of as a high-level
first tip that you want to give out what
do you think holds people back on
YouTube from having the success that
maybe they deserve or should have what
do you think I think it can be a little
overwhelming for people to consider
talking on camera I mean even I my
sister is a business owner and she's
still trying to wrap her mind around the
whole thing you know it's not just like
listening to me doesn't always mean it's
gonna happen but a lot of people look at
the camera and they're like oh that's a
little intimidating I think that holds a
lot of people back that's sort of like
the first thing because we're in our own
heads a little bit too much and also
YouTube is kind of a monster to take on
it's not the same as all the other
social networks because if you're going
into YouTube fresh it's fresh and
there's not a whole lot happening so
that can take some time to kind of grow
momentum there so is all of those things
considered that that can make somebody
kind of shut down and not get started at
all but I think the biggest issue with
that barrier is is not really zeroing in
on the importance of your message
because I think once you do that a lot
of fears and walls start to fall down
because if something is so important
that you've got to get it out there and
you know someone that needs to hear it
and you have this information inside of
you or this entertainment inside of you
that you just must share when you focus
on that and that becomes the important
thing we can start to not be so afraid
of the things that are holding us back
internally it's the importance of the
audience and what you have to deliver
for them so just as you're saying that
we were to have people joining live
watching and for you guys watching live
if you have a question
for Amy put it in all caps it's easy to
find clash game or XPS
is asking talking on camera looks scary
and he's concerned about the idea of
that the video is going to be there
forever
so this first video that you have that
may not be good quality is your first
attempt that is going to live forever
and people will always be able to see it
what advice do you have there so
everyone always asked this question
right like oh I'm so much better than I
was before maybe I can delete my old
stuff and I actually think that that's
that's something you shouldn't do and
you should be totally fine with
publishing it the luxury we have on
YouTube is building the archive we we
want that video to be there forever it's
not very many places where we can create
something that's valuable for someone
and it still be working for us four five
six years later one of my most popular
videos is from a very long time ago you
know maybe my hair wasn't perfect maybe
the environment wasn't perfect the
lighting wasn't that good but that video
is still crushing it and it's helping
people so I would challenge you to think
how if I if I'm going to be embarrassed
of this video down the road have it be
for the wrong reasons so that the right
reasons are so strong like how well you
delivered the information and how
confident you were and how evergreen
that is going to be to help you over the
long term that it's going to stay there
and work for you and you won't want to
delete it I actually think it's just so
important to hit publish and practice
practice practice practice the only way
to practice and we're preaching the
choir here because Evan practices the
publish button every single day very
regularly many times a day you got to do
that and get the content out there to
get the feedback to get better to grow
and if I didn't have those first videos
that are like just okay I wouldn't be
here right now and that's what keeps
people I think from getting better is
because they get to much again in their
own heads about it and and they're like
ah well I don't really like how it looks
so I'm just going to stop well it's not
going to get better then you've got to
practice so I would say get into it be
okay with the fact I say this from the
stage all the time when I'm speaking
about video I say your first video is
gonna suck like it's gonna be bad let's
just put it out there it's gonna be bad
so you better just get it done and then
move on to the next one and the next one
and they're gonna suck much
more progressively less than the
previous and you'll be in a good place
before long I think too it shows you the
journey yeah inspiration right people
look at you now and say Amy or such a
natural you're so great at this and
meanwhile you've done all these videos
like go back look at my first one wasn't
so good and they can see that journey as
an inspiration for the work that you're
doing absolutely it's sort of meta
though for me because I get the luxury
of being like ok I could take it as a
total time to be like sad inside when
someone says oh my gosh Amy I was so
afraid to make video but then I watched
your first videos and I'm I'm thinking
I'm gonna go ahead and do it too because
if you can do it and those were your
first videos then I can do it too that
could sound really bad like I would take
that personal bye don't because I sort
of have this meta situation of my job is
to make you want to do video so my
journey makes you want to do video
because you can see how far I've come
and therefore you can too but I think
you can feel that way even if you're not
trying to tell people how to share their
story with video you can still feel that
way about your own database it's got to
be there and we see it all the time on
YouTube where people feel like their
YouTube channel looks so bare well
that's because you're afraid to hit
publish on everything so just get it out
there and do your best work hmm do you
have a recommendation for how much
people should be practicing um well
here's the crazy thing is that going to
YouTube Nextup they they really brought
me back in terms of like how often you
should be publishing because I was
publishing super regularly I was one of
the only people there that had a regular
schedule everyone else was like whatever
I can get it done I was publishing three
days a week religiously for a number of
years but industry-standard on youtube
is once a week and I found that
interesting because I do think that's a
good recommendation if you're just
getting started do a really good job on
your once a week video and then learn
how to market it because when you do
that and you don't just get into the
turn of doing videos all the time you
learn how to market really well and then
every video works its hardest for you
because at the beginning especially
you've got you've got to get some
momentum there to start growing
subscribers and views so it is better to
make something really good and then
spend time marketing it so you can make
every project after it matter even more
but I can also see people posting more
than that
because it's 2017 and we've got
smartphones and there's a million
different ways to make video and soon I
think we're going to be more seamlessly
live-streaming to YouTube with our
phones so there's a lot of ways you can
publish more regularly but I think we
should be thinking about that and adding
in the component of how much time does
it take to make the video and market it
so that we're making the most of all of
that time because on YouTube you're
going to need it and if you want to grow
mmm so I mean I'm sure you get into this
in your vlog like a boss book you guys
can go check that out but in terms of
the marketing side so if I've now made a
new vlog you know Evan visits New York
City and here's my day what am I now
doing to market it for the rest of the
week well I think what's really cool is
first of all really staying focused on a
theme of like what is this video about
it's not just every single second of the
day let's share it but what is this
video really about what is that what
does it take away we want people to have
because I think that's going to help you
have more sound bites within you can
market a video as a whole you know
across your social media but there might
also be bits and pieces inside that
video that you can share maybe there's a
good Instagram moment maybe there's a
behind-the-scenes thing you can be doing
with snapchat I don't think people think
about the repurposing of a video quite
enough because we put so much energy
into creating one project but there's
also probably 10 different things in
there that would make that one piece of
content marketable and so how can you
live stream something on Instagram while
you're making that project to get the
anticipation up about it is there a
screen capture from that video that you
can post to Instagram with a quote that
would make it interesting for someone to
click in your bio to go watch that video
I think that it comes down to the focus
of the video what's the takeaway need to
be so that you constantly are thinking
about how to make this project better of
little sound bites and opportunities to
leverage across all of the social
platforms especially in a place like
Facebook where if you made something for
YouTube it's not always the best project
for Facebook so what is really cool in
that video that you could share there I
just did some people know me for musical
book reviews that I've done for Gary
Vaynerchuk because I guess I'm a Gary
fangirl and I finally you know did my
third music video but it was for myself
this time and I just did that on launch
day on the 31st but for Facebook
you know it's not quite in my opinion as
interesting of a video because it you
have to really be moving around a lot to
pull people in so we just took a 20
second clip of it and uploaded it to
Facebook so that you could click over to
YouTube to watch the whole thing that
way if you're pulled in by it you can
take that next step and have the full
experience over there so I think you
have to just think about what is the
context of every network and how do we
make it perfect for that network and
that's how you'll find all these
opportunities throughout your one video
project to market it I wonder how much
of your marketing is based off of
leveraging your other networks like
going to Instagram and snapchat in
Facebook and Twitter and then driving
traffic back to it versus using other
people's networks to recommit so like
this you know introducing you to my
audience people may know knew how much
and how much of that do you do with your
videos or do you feel like that you get
the best bang just trying to build up
your own platforms on on the other
social networks I think collaboration is
super important but at the same time I I
will also be the first to say I could
probably have done it even more
intentionally than I have in the last 6
years um but I've actually had some
amazing collaborations that have done
great work for me my personal opinion is
if I continue to make the best possible
project for my community as possible
they're going to be the best
word-of-mouth of all time this social
proof that Evans like I want to have a
me on and and maybe somebody'll find her
interesting and go over there it's huge
for me but no one's going to love me
more than my community who I'm making my
content for and once you become a part
of it you kind of grow because of that
in terms of the social networks I
leverage any momentum I can I find my
content on YouTube is so important
especially in those first couple of days
where it's really trying to find its
footing in the YouTube world of
referrals and search I'm going to send
everyone to YouTube to check that stuff
out I'm not necessarily going outside of
my own Network for every single upload I
think it has to depend on the situation
because again this is for my community
they're the best network I could have so
I'm going to go to Instagram and let
them know with stories that I'm pushing
the publish button and then I go to
Twitter to like drop a Jif in to be like
hey you guys there's a video coming and
then there's this whole sort of like get
the anticipation up
that people go and watch I think that's
what people don't think enough about is
how can you leverage those networks but
do it in a way that makes sense for each
of those places that people will
actually take the call to action because
just because you posted a link somewhere
doesn't mean people are going to click
it how are you actually making it worth
their while and so that's why I I
leveraged my own community more than I
leveraged everyone else's but when I
actually have a value prop for everyone
else's I'm going to go there and say hey
what do you think about teaming up on
this because I think your community
would love it I like it I like it we're
getting a question from linger magazine
that kind of touches on what you said at
the beginning about the different
platforms basically try to understand
the difference between YouTube Vimeo
everywhere else that you want to be
posting video you know as YouTube's dead
should we still be focused here what are
your thoughts so I love when people ask
me if YouTube is dead because it's the
second largest search engine in the
world to Google and that's his adopted
mom so it's like really is YouTube dead
I think what I wish people would think
more about is the type of video in all
of these places and how different they
actually are the other social networks
that are coming to light now are
actually making YouTube even stronger
because of the conversation of video as
a whole that's happening because of it
so let's let's paint like a really
literal picture though when you go to
YouTube to watch a video when you
clicked on this video you saw a headline
and a thumbnail and that pulled you in a
notification maybe a headline and a
thumbnail that pulled you in when you're
on Facebook you're hanging out with your
friends you're stalking your ex you're
checking in on Grandma
you know grandma's checking in on the
grandkids like there's a whole different
situation happening on Facebook when a
video shows up on your feed and just
starts playing without any audio so
that's a very unintentional view so even
though we've been there making friends
and building communities so it seems
like it's a lot easier to get views over
there it's a different type of view we
have a little bit of a not harder but
just a different type of way of pulling
people in than we do on YouTube so
that's why I say a video on YouTube is
not always the same for Facebook so we
have to think about that when you're
considering Vimeo usually I say in that
case you know is your video a fine piece
of art that
to be paid for or only really respected
by a very small niche community and not
on the intention of being discovered on
the second largest search engine in the
world then go to Vimeo then that makes
sense I will use Vimeo for more course
like content things that are behind a
paywall or behind an opt-in wall or
something like that
versus YouTube just because I like the
customization but that's just a
preference I could use YouTube too for
that but YouTube you're being discovered
and people are deciding to come to you
because of your thumbnail and headline
it's not the same as an autoplay on
Facebook so there's that personally I
think video on Instagram is what made it
almost lose to snapchat which is why
them store stealing stories made it all
kind of work out again because nobody is
sitting on Instagram and just watching a
video they're scrolling and double
tapping and scrolling and double tapping
and that's it that's all they want to do
they want to look at pretty things and
like them so how do you make video for
that context now we see those like
boomerangs because you don't have to pay
attention to those they're hilarious and
and then Twitter is jiff land in my
opinion or gift land depending on what
you prefer you have to remember people
are on the go what speed are they
looking at content in all these places
how do they like to watch it and what
makes sense it's going to make you go oh
my gosh every one of these needs a
different kind of video and that's where
the wheels start to turn on repurposing
and marketing properly okay Sebastian is
writing Evan how can I buy a book from
Germany and we talk about my book or
yours but mine is on Amazon we've lost a
German customers on I am both there on
there are you do you have like multiple
versions you have an eBook version you
have an audio versions that come in
what's the audio version we'll be out
later I have the hardback paperback and
Kindle in in Amazon right now so if you
got a vlog like a boss comm you can find
the links to everything there but yeah
we have we have we have everything
except for audio but audio is on its way
cool are you doing the honor yourself oh
yeah oh my gosh
so I just did my first like book reading
at a signing last night which is it was
super emotional so I had a hard time
getting through it but I feel like
because I make videos it's only right
that people get to hear my personality
come through in my own book there's no
way I could go with any other option I
was the exact same way it was
fun it was me on fire recording it's no
fun
I'm excited to hear yours uh okay art
and homesteading to what degree is
personality I'm more important than
content more or less important than
content in other words should I spend
more time on my in front of camera
skills or my research slash subjects I
think you you need to know your game I
mean that's really important especially
these days where if it's as easy as
taking a selfie to get attention the
competition for being a thought leader
in your space is going to become much
higher you need to know your stuff so
content is extremely important I would
also say it's important because I don't
read a prompter I don't have a script so
when I'm looking at the lens of a camera
like it's a person I should probably
know what I'm going to say so that has a
lot to do with that too just prepping
for that conversation so content is
extremely important but that's where the
personality just takes its own way into
the into the situation I'm not
customizing my personality right I'm
just telling you what I know and so this
is my personality it's the one I was
born with it's the only one I get it's
the only one I need and that's what
you'll read that in the book I think a
lot of people deal with that and I did
too I wasn't a ham for the camera when I
was growing up I just figured out how
important my message was and just
started delivering it that's it so I
think it's knowing the content knowing
it really well and delivering it to the
person you're thinking of and looking at
them and saying it using the camera that
way and then you've done your job in
terms of personality because it's just
going to be you talking to someone then
I like it now you talked about the
importance of a message a couple times
for people who aren't familiar with your
YouTube channel what is the message of
savvy sexy social when they come and
check out your videos so I mean I just
want you to come to my channel and and
feel motivated and equipped to go after
the life you want and I do a lot of that
through teaching you how to use
different vehicles to delivering your
message like social media and video but
sometimes it's productivity and end time
and time management because sometimes we
just can't figure out how to fit
everything in in a day and that really
keeps us from getting it done and
therefore we're not going after the life
we want I want everyone to feel like
they can its 2017 if you're not happy
with your life
you can change it you can make it happen
but don't make yourself think you can't
any video that I have delivers on that
and and I'm very adamant about giving
you something actionable always because
hyperbole is is wonderful and it's
motivational but at the same time I need
something here like give me something to
do right now cuz I'll do it I'll test it
and I will let you know if it worked and
I want my community to do that always so
come to my channel if there's something
you want to do or something you want to
say or a change you want to make and you
just need to know how to do it I like it
well you have some fans already in the
chat Raquel Carter I love Amy
exclamation point thank you next
question this is a super common question
I don't know if you address this in your
in your book blog like a boss but let me
know Kenson how do I figure out the best
camera and mics to use I do talk about
gear although I almost thought like
wouldn't be funny if I did a book about
video and didn't talk about gear because
I'm always telling people like stop
worrying about the gear but here's the
thing it there's it's a good
conversation I'm going to start by
saying do what you can with what you
have where you are Theodore Roosevelt
that's I mean like that's what you need
to know right now it's 2017 you have a
way better camera than I did when I
started 10 years ago ok so just use the
thing and that's the basis of what I'm
going to say there are tools to help you
edit on that phone you can edit on on
web browsers and the accessibility is
unmatched than ever before so there's
that prove to yourself that you need to
upgrade to get all the fancy gear like I
make myself feel the pain of not having
gear before I'll go buy it so I know I
make every dollar worth it but that's
when you know it's time to upgrade and
just get the camera that you know how to
use and set up your space I love when
people just pick a corner of their
office or their house and the camera
just sits there until they have
something to say and they'll go stand in
front of it and say it because that's
really powerful when you get into that
habit which is what I've always had I've
got my bookshelf when it's time to talk
camera up let's go lights on talk and I
think that's the best moment you can
capture with video if that's easier for
you with a smartphone do it because
you've got it I mean
most of us do and so that's really
important but prove to yourself you need
the fancy gear I absolutely have a
chapter on that I also have a page on my
website dedicated to that but a lot of
people will just jump on buying that
stuff and not even know really what to
do with it I would challenge you to take
action on making video before you worry
about the equipment I love it
I agree Mack writing in I'm starting a
weight loss journey and I want to start
vlogging my journey do you think I'll
have success in YouTube showing my
journey and you have any tips for me to
start this I absolutely think their
success in that because the greatest
thing about a vlog is you're just simply
telling a story no matter how it is and
you are just simply doing that I just
met someone the other day that that told
their trans gender transformation story
and that was just here's what's
happening just letting you know this is
how I feel about it this is what's hard
and I would figure it out I feel like
anyone that's going through a process
I just documented 31 days of launching a
book that's a process you know sharing
that story people like to see that
because not only can you tell them what
you know but they're actually seeing the
experience happen so they know you know
and sometimes people need that when they
Knight might not have as much confidence
in their thought leadership on what they
know if they feel like they're just
simply telling you what happened then
we're all pretty clear as the audience
like well that's what happened and
that's how they feel and today has been
a hard day yesterday was a good day and
it's nice to see that weight loss
journey is that's one of the most
motivational things I think you could
watch on YouTube because when you see
someone make a change in their life I
think that's why a lot of us gravitate
toward this platform and decide to make
video or tell our story in some capacity
because we've seen what changes someone
has made in their life simply by getting
on video and talking about it my tip
would be um and this is tough for me too
so I'll just I'll just put it out there
don't be afraid to get vulnerable which
automatically what you're doing is
pretty vulnerable but I think you have
to be really true about what you're
feeling and not every day is going to be
a great day and you're gonna know that
it's so hard to look at the camera and
not be negative I think I think we all
want to be really positive
but your I think that your journey is
going to be more impactful for someone
if they really know what they're signing
up for if they maybe follow in your
footsteps and - here you go like I just
want a piece of freaking cake so bad I
think being that transparent is what
gets people hooked and I would say don't
be afraid of that vulnerability Cool J
Green running in how to use how do you
decide what videos to make so a lot of
it I have the fortunate luxury of having
a community that tells me you know they
will just tell me all the time with what
they want but I
what's my promise that's to make sure
that somebody learned something from me
and has a good time and can take action
on making a change in their life that's
the promise that I've made so any video
that I want to make in that regard falls
into that category but at the same time
I'm a specialist when it comes to online
communication so it's going to be toward
that area and then you can actually read
in my book about how I bucket content so
what are the different categories that I
want to play in and then when I come up
with a topic idea it goes into a
category which lands at a place on the
editorial calendar and everything really
like plans itself out instead of the
run-and-gun like I'm going to do this
video now I'm going to do that video now
that can start to get a little
exhausting for people and you won't
maybe stick with it so I do believe in
the editorial calendar and setting it up
for success and those are sort of the I
plan my buckets and I put content in
those buckets and it's all about you
know bettering your life time management
social media video and and how can I
help you do that right now because
that's what I specialize in go for it so
that's that's how I come up with what to
talk about and you'll often find when
you do one video what happens in the
comments is they'll say another question
or they'll say wouldn't it be cool if
she did a video on this since just like
write that down even if you're not ready
for it or if it's if it's down the road
or it's not quite a fit just write it
down because having that feedback is so
huge it is such a blessing that
someone's telling you what to do because
they're saying we will watch that that's
big so really leverage any opportunity
to ask I always say when you don't have
a network yet let's say you're starting
with zero go ask the people you know
what's the first question you think of
or what's your frequently asked question
about what you do really well or see if
they even know how to articulate what
you do when you ask people that they
will tell you what they're thinking and
usually that's what they're popping into
Google if that's ever an issue in their
life and that's a good place to be when
you're making content what are people
going that you know how to answer
that's content I like it uh Impractical
Jokers full punishments is asking about
basically how to use Facebook to drive
more YouTube views do I upload the video
to Facebook is it just linking it to
Facebook and it hopefully goes to
YouTube was it doing short clips I know
how to use Facebook to drive more
YouTube views so I've done a number of
different things for myself for clients
and there's a there's something powerful
in being able to upload native video
because Facebook loves native video
right now so meaning I'm going to upload
this clip to Facebook not to youtube but
to Facebook I don't like to upload an
entire video to Facebook unless it's
been on YouTube for a certain amount of
time because that's where I choose to
put my momentum if you would prefer to
grow a Facebook platform then go hard
there and upload but I also would say
that you could do something a little
different and and this is really
powerful right now because of how much
Facebook loves live video going live on
Facebook and saying or while you're
uploading and say you know answering
questions and saying I just posted a
video on YouTube and it's about this do
you guys have questions about this or
what do you guys think about it or have
you had any experience with this and
having a real conversation with people
in facebook all the while your youtube
link is in the caption of that live
stream so that you get a lot of momentum
on that post with the live video on
Facebook that's probably going to be
with engagement it could be on the feed
for 24 hours depending on how things go
you've got that youtube link sitting
there and you can get some traffic over
I feel that's the best way to get those
links clicked over from Facebook right
now because of how much Facebook Likes
live but I also love to just post my
thumbnail and I will put the youtube
link in a picture of a thumbnail because
a photo is still technically a native
upload to Facebook so that still works
for me sometimes throughout the month of
documenting
the launch of the book though we did
upload the full episodes of the videos
24 to 48 hours after it was on YouTube
because there was just so much content
to work with and we were movin and
shakin a lot so it's the kind of video
that can pull someone in on the newsfeed
that that helped as well but that wasn't
so much for a youtube view it was just
awareness of the book so think about
what the main goals are and then then
think about okay well what's the main
goal is to get attention on this book
then we're just going to do whatever it
takes if it's for the YouTube view how
do you make sure that it gets there
efficiently I like it HOD 92 any hints
on how to find the message you want to
deliver in your videos Amy I think you
will get a huge hint if you know who
you're talking to very specifically and
knowing who who your avatar is what they
do what their life is like and what
keeps them up at night that's going to
help shape your message I think you know
what you do well and then knowing the
person that you're doing this for well
is going to help you figure out exactly
what your thing is so I'll give you an
example of my channel when I first
started I needed a platform to become a
professional in my industry and at the
time the customers that I was working
with were small businesses in 2010 and
2011 that wanted nothing to do with
social media they were told they needed
a Facebook page they certainly weren't
ready for video yet but what do we do
with this Facebook situation they needed
to learn that they didn't have a budget
for it and they just needed to do it on
their own what I needed to do to show up
and be now considered one of the top
leaders in the space was make it fun for
them because they were doing all this
research and it was a nightmare and they
weren't excited and I just said I'm
going to teach you how to use that
Facebook page but you're going to have
fun while you're learning it from me so
that was really that the first thing
that happened for me so I knew I knew
how to manage a Facebook page so I'll
teach you how but I also know who you
are you're a business owner maybe you've
got a brick-and-mortar this is a total
nightmare that someone's being told
there's a new marketing platform you
need to use and you need to use it now
so let's have fun in this process I'm
going to make my video short because I
no you don't have time and every single
one is going to have a tactic for you to
take forward all of those things came
together as the the message of the of
the channel and then you're you're
really getting focused around who they
are which is the most important thing
but also what you're best at
I think people start to get in trouble
when they go oh that sounds good but
they're not the expert on that thing or
they're not quite as experienced on that
thing but they still try to make a video
on it you want to make sure someone
feels the impact and gets the results
from you every single time so stay
focused on what you're good at but
really understand where they're coming
from I like it now the time is the last
question about having fun and not being
your angle onassis is writing in should
I present myself as a friendly guy or
professional guy I think it should be
both because I think we've learned in
social media that people want to do
business with a person as fluffy as that
sounds right you know we see fewer logos
these days and more faces and I think
that's super important so you should be
friendly because nobody wants to work
with someone that's not friendly but you
can be professional and friendly as well
and you can be professional and friendly
and stand up for what you believe in as
well and so I think all the above I
agree on a percent uh can we focus on
two subjects on our channel and how can
we do that usually when when this
question pops up I feel like it's
because someone's like do I just come up
with a second channel or should we kind
of exert energy into places and I feel
these days in YouTube it's so much
easier to have different kinds of
content on one channel because of the
way that it works that being said the
only reason why two subjects would be on
one channel is if they serve the same
people so if you want to make those two
subjects your sort of brand and maybe
they sound eclectic together that could
be the case in your life who's doing
something like this if you're the first
awesome but make it work because it's
for the one person that's going to find
it and they're going to love it but if
you're like we're going to talk about
dog supplies and we're going to talk
about buying paper if those two things
are not for the same person then maybe
they shouldn't be on the same channel I
think that's how you determine that I
like it that's that's a really good
distinction
uh Leroy how were you able to get out of
your own way in taking that first step
in your business well I think I was
fortunate that people were coming to me
and wanted advice while I had a
full-time job and a lot of people think
that it's like when you make the jump in
entrepreneurship it's big and scary it
certainly is but I did a lot of work
leading up to that big scary decision
even though it was still big and scary
at that time in order to get out of my
own way I think I had to do the work and
prove to myself that I could actually
execute on what I was selling and not
just say like I'm gonna start a business
and think that everyone was coming my
way so I actually did a lot of client
work as what we're calling these days a
side hustle at the time it was just like
what I did at night the passion project
but I did that for about a year and a
half before I finally made the leap to
leaving my job and I took a long time to
be like oh my god I think I'm gonna
leave my job this is so crazy but it
still took me like a whole year to get
to that point the getting out of my own
way happened when I just did the work
and I said now is the time I have
measured my risk reward you know I
didn't have a mortgage I didn't have any
kids and I could kind of make a big kind
of scary decision at the time and some
people don't have that luxury I think
that's what it comes down to I got out
of my own way cuz I measured risk reward
and I did the work and I met people and
as soon as I left that job I had
full-time work coming in as of what it
was freelancing really at the time
because I'd met people I told them I was
going out on my own
I said I'm available for hire do you
know anyone that needs this and I got
out of my own way by pitching myself and
that's probably hardest for most people
selling yourself is not something that
we brush up on when we think of
entrepreneurship we just think we're
gonna write a bunch of blog posts and
make videos and maybe business will come
in you got to sell yourself too and so I
think that's it that's a big obstacle a
lot of people have to hit I love it Amy
it's crazy how half an hour flies by
when we're rich Matan you're getting a
ton of love thanks having an Amy you've
helped me a lot great question for
everyone great answers I want to put
the last one on you I want to talk about
vlog like a boss and I want people to
check it out go to vlog like a boss calm
or Amazon River you buy books what's
something what's an important message
flip from vlog like a boss that we
haven't touched on in this chat that you
think is important for people who want
to have YouTube success that they should
know about
I think people try to figure out how to
be creative these days in video and and
like there's going to be a clear-cut
answer but the epitome of creativity is
truly trying to find where you are and
original and I think I've found a couple
ways that I do that but instead of
asking someone else or asking yourself
how am I going to stand out how am I
going to be creative I think you have to
do the work because that is going to
show up for you you're going to come up
with the craziest ideas and video is the
most fun and exciting ways to kind of
bring them to life and have people
discover you and that's the scariest
thing about the fact that you're doing
this is not only are you so bold as to
make video but you're bold enough to be
creative but that creativity is going to
take you places that you've never been
before so as cut-and-dry and as black
and white is it you'd might want it to
be here all the steps and I give you a
lot of freaking steps in this book
you're also just going to find like how
did you even come up with that idea it's
just going to happen for you and when
you feel that moment of if someone made
this and it wasn't me
and it wasn't my company if someone made
this I would even share it with my
community that's how you know you have
something good something so shareable
you would share it with your friends and
family that's how you know you're onto
something good and that's how you know
you're creative and to go after that
idea and allow yourself to stand out
we're going to stumble we're going to
think things are cool that aren't always
cool but your creativity is going to
come out so hard when you use this
medium and I hope you'll fully embrace
it I love it boom nice final message
thank you guys so much for watching for
asking all those great questions I
encourage you to go check out vlog like
a boss comm or an Amazon where you go
buy your books a me really a me showing
a books you got to say something to show
up on camera Oh
get the book please there it is Amy
thank you for your time as well guys
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon